we have major major major developments
in not only the growing elector revolt
against president-elect Donald Trump but
in Donald Trump's panic about what
electors are doing I have all the
information for you today we are going
to go through it step by step now let me
remind you not to Pat myself on the back
but just to remind you that this is not
a brand new story that I was one of the
first people talking about the elector
revolt on November 30th I told you that
a source of mine communicated that
fifteen of Republican electors were
planning not to vote for Donald Trump
and that they were lobbying quietly
trying to lobby additional Republican
electors not to vote for Donald Trump
the next day on December 1st I told you
about an additional source a well-placed
and successful historically successful
Democratic operative who confirmed that
while it wasn't clear whether the number
was exactly fifteen that yes indeed
there is a group of Republican electors
planning to not vote for Donald Trump on
Monday this week I told you that that
number has grown according to my source
from 15 to 20 electors and now we've
heard from Harvard professor Lawrence
Lessig that indeed there are 20 electors
at least 20 Republican electors planning
to not vote for Donald Trump on December
19th which is starting to get us closer
to the number needed to block Trump from
270 electoral votes that number of
course would be 37 moving away from
Donald Trump's 306 electoral votes this
is in addition to the now 50 electors
that want a briefing on Russian
intelligence before the on Russian
interference in the November 8th
election before they vote on December
19th I will tell you about that later
let's go now to Lawrence Lessig talking
to Chuck Todd making a big announcement
that I made to you two weeks ago and
updated on Monday take a look take a
listen this is to let the electors
exercise their judgment and what we
believe is at at least 37 electors will
make the judgment not to support Donald
Trump
and if that happens then of course it
goes to the house and the house has to
pick among the top three candidates a
week ago there was one Republican
electorate come out and said that he was
not going to vote for Donald Trump what
we believe surveying the three groups
that I'm aware of that are advising and
supporting Republican electors is that
there's at least twenty right now some
tell me that the number is higher than
that it should be more like thirty but I
feel confident saying there's at least
twenty now of course if they don't get
to 37 I doubt any of them beyond the one
chris supra and who's actually come out
in public is gonna vote against donald
trump Wow these are my exact words I
told you there are at least twenty and
there may be more now even if this
happens and the house picks Donald Trump
to be President anyway it still matters
it just builds the historic anti mandate
against Donald Trump losing the popular
vote by nearly three million votes to
Hillary Clinton winning the electoral
vote because of a mere fifty eight
thousand votes in three particular
states and then losing from election day
to December 19th somewhere between one
and thirty six electoral votes if you
want to really judge whether Trump is
worried about this just look at the fact
that the Trump campaign is trying to
legally block a lawsuit that's been
filed in Colorado to unbind electoral
college members from their state's
popular vote outcome in some states this
is a lawsuit we've talked about this
group before the Hamilton electors the
Hamilton electors group of specifically
Polly Baca and Robert Neman each have
filed this lawsuit to unbind electors
from having to vote in certain states
where this is the way that the law is
written for who the candidate that won
the popular vote in their state if this
were not something Donald Trump was
worried about Trump would be silent
about it would be taking no action but
instead the Trump campaign has filed to
block this lawsuit which is evidence
that not only is Donald Trump aware of
the growing elector revolt as I've been
telling you for weeks now but that he is
worried enough about it to actually take
action this is likely going to
be historic at this point no matter what
the outcome is the last time that a
group of electors wrote in a non
candidate was 1960 when 15 electors from
Oklahoma Alabama and Mississippi refused
to vote for Kennedy or Nixon and instead
voted for Harry Byrd
there's been no more than one faithless
elector per election since then and if
more than 15 Republican electors racial
vote against Trump it may not change the
outcome
but it would be a historic protest it
would definitely be a historic protest
but I was just gonna mention there was
also in 1808 when six Democratic
Republican electors voted against J
madethe James Madison so we have seen a
little bit of this yeah there's also
1872 right where we had nearly all of
the electors pledged to Horace Greeley
who had been defeated refusing to vote
for him for you know the understandable
reason that Greeley had died after
Election Day so very particular
circumstances but the big picture is
number one elector revolt is growing big
league number two Trump is clearly
worried about it because he's taking
action with relation to faithless
electors and number three for anybody
saying this is pointless and just to
move on absolutely not this could have
major major implications